[Music]
travis is going to start us off this
hour at lake of the ozarks hi travis how
are you
it's wonderful how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
well i'm just kind of looking for maybe
some insight suggestions
maybe some books to offer up i've been
been in the restaurant business for
about 16
17 years now since i was 15 16 years old
started as a cook worked my way up i now
own two restaurants with my partners
i'm just kind of hitting a wall where
i'm just starting to hit you know
with employees and just getting burnt
out and just kind of in that
um just hard to deal with the with all
the all the extra stuff i guess
you know are you the manager or the
owner of the restaurant
i'm sorry are you the manager of the
restaurant or the owner both
oh so i i had part owner of two or two
of our
or two of our stores and then i managed
the one
okay so hiring goof goof off people that
are driving you crazy is driving you
crazy
yeah yeah yeah that's a good that's a
good part of it
so what specifically it first of all i'm
going to walk you through this a second
but burnout is nothing more than a
symptom
it's a feeling it's real the emotions
and some of the physical playoffs here
but it's not a source it's not it's just
a symptom
so what what specific is your question
or
what is causing you uh the greatest
soul-sucking experience in your current
role
i guess just the just the employee side
i mean just
not getting applications not having the
i'm not getting the help so then i mean
when we are busy it's you know
everybody's short-handed we
you know we've got people that are
working 14 15 hours a day because we
don't have extra
extra help and um you know it's you know
i hate putting my employees through that
um and so then i start to get down on
myself that you know what do i need to
do better
to to get anything to get to get them
some help i guess
right so really you are you are
overwhelmed
your team is overwhelmed and that just
kind of just keeps cycling in and out
and you go i can't do this much longer
that's what you're feeling
yes right right and so your biggest
problem is not being able to find
people who you can actually hire is that
correct yeah
yeah i mean every since the the whole
unemployment you know fiasco i mean
i mean there was an appointment you know
for four months where we didn't have an
applicant over
16 17 years old yeah i mean it was just
all dried up pretty much that was the
stupid but
federal government program yeah that's
over now though
terrible yeah that's over now right yeah
yeah
so is the issue you don't feel you're
finding the quality of candidates or
there are no candidates just no
candidates i mean we've used sag agile
we use indeed we use facebook we use i
mean we've
exhausted all of our you know we upped
our pay we've you know tried to go
through all of the
all the things that we thought would you
know kind of stir some up you know stir
up some talk but i just really haven't
had any success yet
that's very interesting uh because i i
find it i mean it's not that i don't
believe you but i'm having a hard time
understanding if the unemployment
because that was a pure incentive not to
work
for sure but if that is gone i'm curious
to know why there's a
uh a lack of warm bodies that need some
cash we're down to a seven percent
unemployment rate
yeah overall okay so let's back up to
this all right
i i faced the same thing many years ago
in our place here because i mean we're
getting people out of debt that's not
exactly a small
market right you know it's like trying
to catch a freaking title wave with a
tea cup around here half the time
and that's what so it's you're
overwhelmed we were
understaffed perpetually for a decade
we're not overstaffed now but we're not
we don't have anybody killing themselves
because of lack of staff but i
experienced the same
sense of what you're doing and um
so i did a couple of things that began
to fix that
one was i raised our prices
so that we had more money to pay better
okay and i don't know what your price
point is in this restaurant
but raise your prices okay and
and offer more money you know
not just competitive but more than the
competitors
for similar jobs the second thing i did
was
i i decided this is my main problem
this hiring problem is my main problem
and me and two or three of the leaders
dove on that ball and said
we're going to work on hiring until we
fix it we're going to hire recruiters
we're gonna do everything we started
paying a uh referral which we still pay
because if you've if you've got good
people on your team
you know they run around with good
people usually good people
yeah and so i pay 500 bucks referral
if you refer your friend in here and we
hire them and they stay 90 days
and we also tell them don't refer your
crazy friends
i don't need the problem and you don't
want to work with them right
only refer your thoroughbred friends not
your donkey friends
and i'll give you 500 bucks and you know
and you know
on tech we had a real tech shortage we
were paying and we still do pay on some
tech positions a 2
000 referral you know what it created
sixty four percent of the people that we
hired last year came from
internal referrals wow my team became my
greatest recruiter
what are the positions that you need
most is it wait staff
kitchen staff what what is it no the
kitchen staff is good on this
it's the wait staff just the way the
waitress i'm waiting waiting
is this a fine dining restaurant what
what quick service restaurant
well i'm curious because you said some
30's like the only people applying are
16 and 17 year olds
you know listen um i don't know why
i don't know why you aren't open to 16
and 17 year olds because this is
leadership you can train them
you can you know that's my main i mean i
enjoy working with with the kids and and
seeing them grow and growing into
positions and stuff it's
just getting them getting i mean we we
do a hundred dollars
you know if they last 30 days we give
them 100 bucks for the referral program
and i thought you bring me six people
pay 600 bucks you know
and yeah i think you're onto something
there so anyway what i did
to answer your question the way i solved
the problem was i said
we've got to treat this like it's going
to destroy us if we don't fix it
because it's destroying you you called
and said i'm burnt out and i own the
dadgum place
you know and so you know if i don't like
what's going on around here
i can fix it i own it you know or i can
change it i can pay
more work less change the hours raise
the prices you know
institute referral programs raise the
referral programs decide that you're
going to okay this is going to be all
about training teenagers and so you're
going to be known all throughout the
area like chick-fil-a is as being a
place to train a teenager and then
you've got another incentive for people
to want to work there
or whatever but but you know we fixed it
and we've got a substantially better
team oh the last piece is spend more
time
hiring quit using the mirror test to
hire because they fog up a mirror
you're so desperate that you put stupid
butt people on your team and they'll
drive you crazy and they drive your
customers crazy and then you've got to
fire them and start again
it's easier to take to slow down and
don't have to do it as often
yeah and if you want to get 16 to 17
year olds everything dave said yes yes
yes yes yes but i would also get really
intentional about
uh the schools in the area uh the
leaders the coaches
finding the kids that uh i'm not talking
sheer popularity but high character kids
who have influence in that community
because kids will flock to where the
cool kids and where the kids are
they'll go there and that's word of
mouth
exactly on quick surf yep good stuff
good stuff hey man good question hang on
i'm gonna send you a copy of the entree
leadership book
our number one bestseller on how we run
our business here
and it'll help you on some of this you
got a legitimate problem i think you can
solve it though
this is the dave ramsey show